[Music]
breakfast is not only the most important
meal of the day but also the main reason
why we wake up in the morning no matter
how we feel food is always there to turn
a bad day into a good one you might
think that you know everything about
your best friend the chocolate but
you'll be surprised to learn that you
are not eating it the right way make
sure you watch this video until the end
to know what a commercial reveals about
Toblerone if you love food as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're showing you 10 foods you've been
eating wrong strawberries there is a
great reason why we love strawberries it
is the most romantic fruit in the world
you just need a chocolate fondue with
your partner and you can turn one boring
night into one of the most wonderful
dates ever you might think that they are
your favorite berries but you would be
wrong
that's because strawberries are not
actually berries no matter what we call
it people came up with the name before
we actually knew what a berry was but
botanically speaking a berry has three
different layers the outer skin
the fleshy middle and the inner part
which holds the seeds it also needs to
have more than one seed so technically
bananas eggplants and oranges are
berries the blueberry is the only fruit
that was named properly so how do we eat
it most people would just slice down the
leafy end or pull it with their fingers
but there is actually a much better way
to do it to make sure you eat as much
fruit as possible the only thing you'll
need is a straw insert it into the
strawberry nose first and keep pushing
until it pushes the leaves through the
other end maybe this is why we call it a
strawberry this fruit had been telling
you how to eat it for all this time
tic-tac you might think that eating a
tic-tac was a really simple task you
could carry them anywhere with you and
you just had to open this little
container to let a tiny mint fall in
your hand and eat it to have fresh
breath the only difficult thing to do is
making sure that your friends didn't see
that you were eating one when they
noticed you they immediately asked for
one too and you were left with nothing
in this container way too soon but next
time you'll be able to distract your
friends with some fun facts about
tic-tac instead did you know that they
are not the one-and-a-half calorie
breath mint anymore the company started
using the tagline in 1980 but it was
abandoned recently because their size
has increased slightly if you look at
the nutrition facts you'll learn that
there are actually now
one point nine calories in them so now
you can make a joke and tell your
friends that it will be bad for their
diet but if you want to show them
something more interesting tell them how
to eat these little mints if you look
under the flap at the top of the
container you'll see something that will
allow you to extract a single breath
mint in one easy move the company didn't
publicize it in the advertisements but
we think that it is probably not there
for nothing it's worth a try
ketchup fries are the most wonderful
vegetable in the world and ketchup is
the best fruit that we need to eat it so
technically we could say that we're
eating a salad when we go to a fast-food
restaurant but some people just became
crazy and started using ketchup
everywhere they eat cereals with ketchup
instead of milk they serve rice with
ketchup and they think that ketchup
sandwiches are delicious we do think
that this tomato sauce tastes really
good however there is one thing that
makes everyone crazy
no matter how sane you are it is when
there is not enough ketchup left in the
bottle to easily pour some in your
hamburger it just keeps making fart
noises and everyone feels awkward but
don't worry we have some tips for you
first you can put the bottle upside down
in the fridge so what would be easier to
use but if you're at the restaurant and
the waitress hands you a bottle with all
the ketchup stuck at the bottom there is
one thing you can do tap the number 57
on the bottle neck to make the ketchup
pour more quickly and do you want to
know how to put more ketchup into these
little cups too all you have to do is
expand them to make them bigger and you
will be able to have as much ketchup as
you want apples
everyone likes apples unfortunately
there are not a lot of people who would
say that it is their favorite fruit some
people might say that it's because
they're too normal
and we're used to eating them but we
think that this fruit deserves much more
admiration after all they are the reason
why apple pie exists and they are part
of fun party games they are even the
most famous fruits as they had a bad
reputation in the Bible fell on Newton's
head and almost ended the life of a
Disney Princess and if you love apples
you'll be happy to hear that there are a
lot of different fruits that you can eat
there are more than 2,500 varieties of
apples grown in the United States if you
ate one apple a day it would take you
nearly seven years to eat one of each
kind and there are more than 7,500
varieties of apples in the whole world
so
you will need more than 20 years to eat
them however you need to make sure that
you properly eat them when you simply
start by the middle and eat all around
the core
you're wasting 30% of the fruit the best
way to eat them is to start by the
bottom and to eat the whole fruit so yes
that means you can actually eat the core
Chinese takeaways Chinese takeaways are
one of the best things to eat when
you're too lazy to cook and you're tired
of ordering pizzas it comes with a lot
of variety and makes you feel a little
exotic and the warmth of the food is
always comforting we wouldn't think of a
better meal to eat alone on a Sunday
night however don't think that Chinese
takeaways have anything to do with China
what they eat in this country is
actually really different and we know
that real Chinese food is actually much
better than what we usually eat in
America instead of a wonton soup try to
order a shrimp dumpling soup it tastes
much better you can also try scallion
pancakes instead of the deep fried egg
rolls or pay king duck instead of
General Tso's chicken but the best thing
to do if you can afford it is actually
traveling to China and discovering all
the delicious meals you could eat there
but if you can only afford to eat
Chinese takeouts because you don't have
enough time or money to travel there is
something that you need to know when you
unfold the takeout box you can turn it
into a plate all you need is a pair of
chopsticks and you're ready to eat that
delicious American sesame chicken
bananas if you listen carefully to this
video you know that bananas are actually
berries we all love this delicious fruit
but unfortunately we never have enough
time to eat them you buy them when they
are green you wait a few days you
finally have time to eat one perfect
banana and two minutes after they are
all brown no matter what we think that
the weight is worth it and we keep
buying these berries anyway they taste
great in banana and chocolate muffins
even when they are brown but if you want
to peel one properly many people think
that you would have to look at monkeys
however you will be surprised to hear
that wild monkeys do not eat bananas
this is nothing but a mint the bananas
that we eat are actually a domesticated
fruit wild monkeys never see bananas
unless they live near humans these
animals do eat fruits but too many
bananas would actually be bad for their
health because they have lots of
calories and contain much more sugar so
this whole story is nothing but a total
fabrication but that's not a reason not
to eat bananas properly the first
thing that you have to do is to turn the
fruit upside down then you can peel it
from the side without the stem it will
be a little easier to eat this way soda
cans we know that we shouldn't drink too
many of this but we just can't resist
all these little bubbles and the sugar
are perfect to give us a boost of energy
and we have to admit that the delicious
taste also has something to do with that
anyway the first choice that we have at
the restaurant when we are not drinking
alcohol is to order a Pepsi or a Coca
Cola unfortunately it is not the best
choice for our body even though our
taste buds wouldn't agree usually sugar
should make up less than 10% of the
total energy intake per day and it is
even recommended getting it down as low
as 5% which is equivalent to 25 grams of
sugar per day however there are nine
spoons of sugar per each 330 milliliter
serving of Coca Cola and Pepsi this
means that with one drink you already
ate more sugar than what you need in one
day if you're looking for something
sweet orange juice would be a better
alternative but first you need to know
how to use the can no matter what you're
drinking once you pop a soda can tab you
can spin it around and use it as a
perfect straw holder but next time make
sure that you think about eating
something that's a little bit healthier
cupcakes if there is one thing that can
turn a bad day into a beautiful one it
is a cupcake everyone is happy when they
see a cupcake unless you have to buy it
and realize that it cost way too much
for these two bytes but no matter what
we think that a smile is priceless so
we'll buy one anyway a cupcake tastes
just like a cake but it's even cuter and
that's what makes it one of the most
wonderful tiny things in the world but
you know where it actually comes from in
the Middle Ages a cake was a flat round
of bread baked hard on both sides it is
not until the 19th century that the
first cupcakes were created people gave
them this name because they were baked
in cups and made from ingredients
measured by the cupful and nowadays they
have become so popular that the world
record for cupcake eating is 72 in 6
minutes but there is one thing that we
didn't understand through all these
years and it is how to properly eat a
cupcake no matter what we do there is
always frosting all over our face that's
why you need to cut the bottom of the
cake in half put it at the top and turn
it into a sandwich it's not as cute as
it was before but at least you'll look
better eating it pistachios we can't
keep ourselves from evening snack
so at least we'll eat something healthy
and no we are not talking about that
delicious pistachio ice cream
but the pistachio itself we always think
that it is worth it at the end and this
is why we keep opening just one more
pistachio actually they are so good that
they even inspired the pistachio
principle which allows us to become more
satisfied with our food choices
that's because seeing the pistachios in
the shells makes us think that we are
eating more food moreover looking at the
empty shells to see how many pistachios
you already ate will make you eat less
if you give people pistachios with
shells and other people pistachios with
no shells the first one will eat fewer
pistachios or maybe that's just because
they're too hard to open and they're
just tired but you'll be happy to hear
that there is now one great tip that you
can use to easily eat pistachios stop
trying to open them with your hands
until you break a fingernail just take
an empty pistachio shell and use it to
open the new one now you will have the
chance to eat as many pistachios as you
want in less time Toblerone chocolate
will always be there for us chocolate
will never leave us chocolate will never
cheat on us and that is what makes it
one of the best things in the world we
understand why this treat is so romantic
as soon as you eat a piece of chocolate
everything around you becomes more
beautiful and even if your partner
leaves you you will always have some
chocolate to eat when you cry if we
could choose one brand of chocolate that
we would be eating our entire life it
would be Toblerone and we stared at it
for so long that we actually noticed
something special in the logo if you
look closely at it you'll notice a bear
in the mountain that's because the
chocolate was created in the swiss
capital of bern and a bear is featured
on the coat of arms of the town but
let's just let this beautiful chocolate
out of the package and eat it but first
you will have to take a piece of
chocolate in the right way instead of
breaking off triangles by pulling it
away from the rest of the bar you need
to push it closer to the other triangle
if you don't believe us
just look at the commercial to see how
to do it properly is there any other
food that most people have been eating
wrong don't forget to tell us what it is
in the comment section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it for 10 foods you've been
eating wrong for more videos like this
make sure to watch 10 times people
absolutely won the food lottery thanks
for watching
[Music]